if you want to learn how to be a data
scientist because you think this is
interesting then you definitely need to
be involved with Google cloud platform
because one of the best ways to learn
data is using big data and there is a
great set of resources for you in Google
public data sets and bigquery which is
just a great place to get started you
can
there's tons of tutorials that'll help
you there that are available at no cost
the hosting of the data sets is at no
cost and all the work that you need to
do can be done in free tier so there are
lots of ways that even without
participating in a formal training
process or signing up for an exam that
you can grow your skills and really find
a dataset that you're passionate about I
tell people if you love sports look at
sports data if you're concerned about
hunger and poverty look for those
datasets find something you care about
and you will definitely find some trends
that make you scratch your head or make
you angry or make you excited or make
you ask questions so find some data work
with it and change the world